- Dreams do come true!
I've chased one for last 21 years.
When I walk and do bad,
I should know that yes,
I've prepared to the best of my ability.
I couldn't have done anything better.
My father told me that
"Don't, don't look to find shortcuts."
"There are going to be tough
phases in your career."
- He's a former Indian
cricketer and captain.
He's the only player to have scored
100 international centuries.
He's widely regarded as one
of the greatest batsmen of all time.
He's Sachin Tendulkar.
And here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always if he says something
that really, really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
(whooshing noise)
(uplifting string music)
- Something which is
really, really important is,
which I believed, you
have to chase your dreams.
Dreams do come true!
I've chased one for last 21 years.
One World Cup for India, after 21 years.
So dreams do come true.
It may take a bit longer than
some, but they do come true.
Sometimes what happens,
that, we push ourselves,
but not enough, because
we try and then we say,
we find excuses, we say that
"Oh enough, I've tried,
it's not happening."
And you give up.
And one extra step,
success is waiting for you.
Which you sometimes don't end up taking.
So always be prepared to push yourself.
Fearless and, the other way
to describe that is confident.
You know, self belief.
I believe that if you're
confident of your ability,
if you're confident of your
preparations, you know.
Some people call it fearless,
some people call it confidence.
And I feel I'm confident of what I do.
I fail sometimes, I succeed sometimes.
So that's fair enough.
It's a package deal it
comes with that package.
Failures and success, so I
would put it differently.
I'm confident and I trust my instincts.
When I first played for
India, which was my dream,
my father took me aside and told me that,
"You have reached your
landmark, now what next?"
So I told him that "I'm going
to continue playing for India."
So he said,
"You know everything in life
is going to be temporary,
"you'll play cricket
for 10, 15 years, maybe,
"maybe 20 years, but what
happens beyond that?"
"Because everything is going
to be temporary in your life."
"The only thing which will
stay permanently with you
"till your last breath is
the person that you are."
"The nature of a person has to be good."
(crowd cheers and claps)
So he said, "Lot of things will happen
"when you play cricket,
people will appreciate."
"But I would be happier if
people appreciated you more
"as a good person, so try
and be a good person."
And something I would want all of you,
boys and girls to follow, try
and be a good person first.
I think...
to respect your
opposition, your teammates,
is really important.
I can understand everyone
is out there to win.
Not everyone can be winners,
but you can definitely
win everyone's hearts.
You can...
You can win some games,
you can lose some games.
In my career I haven't won all the games,
but something which sport teaches you,
is when there is failure, when
you're faced with challenges,
sport teaches you to get
back on your feet again
and compete harder in the right spirit.
And that's what my
message to you would be,
compete hard, but play
in the right spirit,
and respect your sport above all.
To me, re-match preparation
is extremely important.
Because, that's something
which is within my control.
When I walk and do bad,
I should know that yes,
I've prepared to the best of my ability.
I couldn't have done anything better.
That is when I feel that I'm
ready to go out and play.
There is no player in the
world who can actually walk out
and say, "Today I'm going to score 100."
Or, "I will get minimum
5 kicks and come back."
Sometimes it happens,
sometimes it doesn't happen.
But I believe in controlling
the controllables.
Something where we don't have
control on certain things.
Those things you obviously
cannot waste your energy
in trying to figure out
"How can I control this?"
You would much rather
focus all your energy
on the things that you can control.
Get the best results possible.
But, making an effort is in your hands.
Giving 100% is in your hands.
Sometimes you end up with good
results, sometimes you don't.
Trying, giving 100% is in your hands.
That is what matters to me.
You all have dreams, you
all have vision and life.
Of what you want to be.
To become a priceless, precious diamond.
You all are talented, you
all are sent down by God
with some of the other talent.
We just need to identify that.
And then from an uncut, unpolished diamond
to become a polished, priceless diamond,
it is a process,
it's a journey where
the path won't be easy.
Sometimes when you're
trying to do certain things,
there might be obstacles.
Don't give up, don't find shortcuts.
I think it is important to
follow the right path always.
And in tough times, tough men last.
So I'm very, very confident
that if you follow
the right things in life,
you will be able to achieve your dreams.
To me, cricket taught me a lot of things.
Right from my school days, cricket,
taught me to prepare for an event.
To plan how I want to move forward.
And then to be able to execute those plans
was even more important.
My father was a writer, he was a poet.
He said, "Whatever you want to be in life,
"I don't expect you to become a poet,
"your passion is cricket,
so in cricket you make sure
"that you give your best."
(uplifting music)
My father told me that
"Don't, don't look to find shortcuts."
"There are going to be
tough phases in your career,
"it doesn't matter if you fail
following the right path."
"So, keep following the right path."
"As long as you know you,
your heart tells you that yes,
"today you've tried your best."
"That is what I expect from
you, nothing more than that."
Any team sport, there are
certain teams targets.
And those targets should
always be in the forefront.
And then you'll always find
in a team sport on a given day
they'll be certain individuals
who would perform better
than the other ones.
You just need to understand that
the guys who are in great form,
the others have to play
around them and chip in.
In any, whichever manner possible.
And I feel great individuals
and great performances build a team.
Which produces brilliant performances.
You need solid individuals
who come together
and play as a team and
then achieve the results,
which we all aspire to.
It is fantastic to be part
of Indian cricket team,
last so many years that I've been part of.
I've thoroughly enjoyed.
There have been ups and downs,
but it has taught us a lot in life.
Going with the team
through those ups and downs
is a terrific journey.
I have thoroughly
enjoyed being part of it.
No just to clarify to everyone,
that I don't play for milestones.
(uplifting string music)
I play for India.
The dream was to play for India.
(powerful orchestral music)
(crowd cheering)
Thank you very much.
If I missed out on saying something,
missed out on a few names
I hope you understand.
Goodbye.
(crowd cheering)
- [Crowd] Sachin, Sachin, Sachin, Sachin.
Sachin, Sachin, Sachin, Sachin.
Sachin, Sachin.
Sachin, Sachin, Sachin.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Binay asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of the top 10 rules meant the most to you,
had the biggest impact, what
did you really take from this.
I'd love to hear from you.
Please leave it in the comments,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing noise)
- I always wanted to win the world cup.
That was the reason I started.
And as the time went by I
started enjoying cricket,
and I started realizing
the challenges of cricket.
And my coach was instrumental
and along with my brother.
- [Interviewer] Had you--
- To my elder brother
Ajit, to make me realize
the importance of leading
a disciplined life,
a focused life.
And to,
to make me push harder,
they found reasons and even
towards the end of my career,
I followed that formula.
If I scored once, let the rest
of the world talk about it.
I think about the next game.
And that, right from my school days became
an unwritten formula, an
unwritten law at home.
That we don't talk about last game,
we talk about next game.
And however many runs I score,
I wanted to go out and
score more than that.
So, if I didn't score, I
would have a restless night.
If I scored runs, I would
still have a restless night.
Thinking that, how am
I going to score more?
And that's how it all happened, I mean I,
I normally don't discuss numbers
but this is something that I
must share with all of you.
Towards the end of my
school cricket career,
I already started playing
first-class cricket.
And the last season I can proudly say that
I averaged thousand and 25,
because I only got out
once in the whole season.
(crowd and interviewer laugh)
- [Sachin] And.
My...
My brother and my coach
was instrumental in that
because every time I scored runs,
none of them said "Well
played" to me and that's why
in my farewell speech, I said to my coach,
"At least now you can take a
chance by saying well done."
(interviewer and crowd laughs)
- There are no more matches in my career.
But, something that I lived for
was appreciation from
my coach and my brother.
Which never happened.
And that was something
which, you know sort of
kept me giving my best all the time.
Every individual it is important
to have some kind of exercise
and lead a healthy life.
For me I feel, you know,
just the basic training
just to keep in good shape
and then during the season
and off-season we have different plans.
And sometimes it is about
improving your fitness.
just maintaining that level.
So it depends what phase
you're going through,
during the season.
Obviously it is difficult
to push hard all the time
because you're playing matches.
But, just preseason is the period where
one would want to try harder
and improve the fitness level.
But generally, in between
the matches it is to
do with just maintenance and recovery.
You need a good recovery
session so that you're fresh
for the next game.
Then go out there and perform
equally or even better.